[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club round 2 of the
summer classic here in st. Louis in the
group a key matchup Geoffrey Jean could
not defend his black against version a
cobia a Cobian looks for redemption
after his US Championship performance he
is two for two
joining bar at the perfect top the seat
Dhirubhai Lee throttled Alexander in
judge with the threat of two passed
pawns
Group B saw Poland's Camille dragon rise
to an uncontested lead at the expense of
tanta of Abraham Ian also Andre stuck
open won a battle of Russians against
Vladimir bellows round three coverage
starts now 20 international chess
professionals compete in st. Louis as us
chess champs calm presents the first
ever summer chess classic
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the st. Louis
chess club studio and the 2018 summer
test classic I am women Grandmaster
Katharina Nemcova and I am here with
international master Eric Rosen today we
have the third round of the summer chess
Classic Tournament but before we delve
into the games that are being played
right now let's see what happened
yesterday that's right we have a very
exciting day yesterday with two decisive
games
Virginie Cobian defeating jeffrey zhang
and a very instructive endgame that
jeffrey will have to recover from today
we also had the sifter Bailey defeating
Alexander in judge two to get off to a
very quick starts so this takes us to
our standings where we have version the
Cobian and received our Bailey leading
the pack with perfect two out of two
scores
Sam Savion right behind and clear third
place with one and a half out of two
points and unfortunately for Alexander
in judge not the best start we'll see if
he can regroup for today absolutely
let's say he improves so let's see what
happened yesterday in Group B and in
Group B we had another two decisive
games andrey zhuk open defeating
vladimir Bellis and camille dragon
defeating tata of abraham ian if we take
a look at the standings we can see
Camille dragon is leading the pack
perfect two out of two the only perfect
score in Group B we have JJ ally mirandy
and andrey zhuk open right behind with
one and a half of the two and
unfortunate for vladimir Bellis not the
best start with your attitude
yes and to review the tournament format
we have a 210 player round robins the
time control is 90 minutes 440 moves +
30 minutes for the remainder of their
game with a 30 second increment from of
one and we should keep in mind that
there is a 30 move no draw rule meaning
players cannot accept drawers before
move 30 this should lead to some very
exciting and fighting chess so we will
have a lot of ahead of us so let's see
the schedule for this tournament
right we have games starting at 1:00
p.m. every day until the last day where
games start at 11:00 a.m.
st. Louis time and if there's a tie in
either group there will be a playoff at
5:00 p.m. on Wednesday the 23rd I know
we would both like to see that happen
yes I look forward to see playoff they
are always so interesting but let's see
what is happening today so we have the
pairings for round three in Group A we
have Sam Savion against Benjamin book
Daniel Friedman against CRO jariabek
Alexandre Indyk against Peter Prohaska
Jeffrey Zhang against Vasek Dhirubhai Li
and Renaud Juma buyeth against var
Akopian
and the key matchup for this round is
Jeffrey Zhong against Wasif Terre Bailey
Jeffrey coming back after a tough loss
yesterday Wasif trying to keep the
momentum up with two out of two let's
take a quick glance at that game and see
how the play is developing we can say we
can see both players intently focused on
the board
Jeffrey appears to be maybe fathoming
fathoming the position here we have a
very interesting move that was just
played Bishop to c8 putting the bishop
on the last rank attacking the knight on
d7 Wasif responded with the move Queen
d8 and this brings us to the current
position where it seems like a very
complex battle ahead yes and it's
interesting to note that these
grandmasters are not only 26 plus rated
but they have some huge achievements
both are world champions
Jeffrey Zhang he wondered Junior World
Championship received he won the World
Youth Championship so they have huge
experiences in many many positions let's
take a look at the the pairings for
Group B we have a lot of exciting
matchups today we have Tata Abraham Ian
against Dean our Asadullah Kesava Josh
Reed L versus Camille dragon Robert
August Arion against Sergey mishchenko
Vladimir ballast against Alejandro
Ramirez and JJ ollie mirandy drawing
Andres to cope in and what was a pretty
dry and somewhat boring game and the key
matchup for today in Group B is Josh
fried L against the leader of grow big
cameo Dragoon right and let's go ahead
and take a look at
at that game we had a very fighting
opening resulting from a Kings Indian
attack Black has just played the move a
take b5 which brings us to the current
position Josh is probably trying to
decide where it's a where to put the
knight on from c4 should he move 93
should he perhaps go for the more exotic
95 seems like a very complex battle and
it's interesting we're looking at this
game couple of minutes ago and we saw
how it's kind of equally we thought the
players are gonna fight but now we see
it's very open of course there is no
clear draw they are really gonna fight
they're gonna have a difficult game
against ahead of them so let's see what
are the prices that they are fighting
for yeah we have a very generous prize
fund for group a $22,000 up for grabs
with a $6,000 first-place prize
I'm sure the players will be taking
every game very seriously and the prize
fund is also very generous for Group B
we have the total price under 40,000 and
the winner takes 4000 home yeah and
especially towards the end of the
tournament every half point counts the
players will be fighting hard to to rack
up their points and then fight for a lot
of cash so I'm exciting what's happening
right now so let's see one of these
games yeah one of the games that really
pops out is a battle between Alexander
and jet and Peter Prohaska keep in mind
in judge got off to a very poor start
zero out of two he's looking to
hopefully scrape off at least a half
point in this game but the position
looks very scary for white with Bach
having just played the move pawn b3
going for the the queenside pawn store
I'm trying to create a passed pawn and
hopefully score a touchdown on the Queen
side and he thoughts about this position
it looks like black has no fear he just
want to push the pawns promote still
Queen and make it simple make it easy
but of course the center that black that
white is having with the pawns it it may
not be that easy but we should actually
go back and take a look how this
position occurred
because it came from a very strange
strange idea from the opening we had a
pretty standard Queens gambit declined
position with both sides developing very
normally Bishop's got traded on e7 and
the the weirdness start started with the
move h4 from from in judge which kind of
comes out of nowhere and if we see how
the game proceeded 97 g4 seems like in
judge has no fear going for the the
immediate King sight pawn storm and I
know this this idea is is somewhat new I
believe Alexander's Chabal of well known
player from the US is is maybe most
notable for playing this early pawn
storm on on the Kings side but sometimes
that the problem with extending your
pawns too early is the fact that pawns
can't move backwards yes and we also to
keep in mind that like didn't do
anything wrong he just developed his
pieces he tried to improve so what is
the one who is doing some irregular
irregularities so that seems really not
very good because we see the pieces on
the last rank or there is no castle so
there are some difficulties that white
may face as a consequence of these
decisions yeah and one thing to point
out like whites King doesn't have a
long-term place of safety I mean because
the pawns are so overextended on the
Kings side the King I mean if it stays
in the center it's it's not gonna be
beneficial for whites rooks to get into
the game so if we take a look at how
White's King I've dealt with the
resulting position it just kind of
stayed on e1 and and white had to be a
bit creative with the rook bringing it
from f3 and an eventual rook f6
meanwhile black was just making progress
on the Queen side going for the pawn
advance I would have to prefer black in
the current position but it seems like
it's gonna be a very sharp game I would
not be surprised if this game as its
decisive I'm just curious what white is
gonna do about this thing because this
is very easy plan for black he just
wants to promote the pawns that's right
and because of the pawn tension between
a 2 and B 3 we might expect
something like like a take b3c take b3
but I have a feeling this this rook on
f6 I know it looks impressive but it
might be a bit out of play and if the
rook comes to a square like c6 black
could happily trade and then play a move
like rook b8 and when you get the rook
behind the passed pawn it becomes a
peacock becomes pretty menacing and
white would not like to play a move like
Queen B - for multiple reasons Queens do
not like to block a passed pawns also
the Queen is tied down to the e4 pawn so
it seems like a lot of chances for black
to come out on top in this game plus the
black is also the a-sun phone that can
join the party that is true yeah Black
has has two connected passed pawns if we
go back to the current position assuming
these pawns do get traded passed pawns
are very very valuable especially in
these these late middle game early
endgame positions where you want to
create some worry for your opponent's so
let's see another game what about Daniel
Freedman against ER Oh terrible
yeah that game we saw maybe a late
middle game early endgame with Queens
off the board and there are some
significant imbalances in this position
and just before we talk about it more
there is a game result where Robert
Alcazar Ian drew against our game at
xango so let's see what was the final
position yeah we were actually taking a
look at this game before the broadcast
and we see we see Mike Hummer there with
the Kings across from each other with
kind of the vgt seeing that it's a draw
the game was pretty complex when we saw
earlier but it appears that that they
actually agreed to a draw where they
gain anything to draw before move 30 so
there's repetition so it took play-doh
Sweet Pea deposition three times
that's a draw by the rule that's right
if we look at this position the night
went back and forth between D 2 and F 3
the bishop going back and forth between
east 6 and d5 where the player is just
scared to play on or do you think
they just wanted a an easy day at the
office and and maybe get some rest for
the future rounds I thought this was a
very interesting position for black
because black has pair of bishops the
rookies on open file it's important to
know that black is pawn down which can
make things difficult but I thought
there is enough compensation but when we
see this position and the move Knight f3
in the final position if black does not
go back with Bishop d5 white may play
Bishop b2 you should be too opposite me
show me - we should be - is a
possibility as well of course and then
rook a d1 or rook f d1 and what can
develop back and I'm just as white I'm
pawn up so I understand it black maybe
didn't want to allow this and when for
the forced Bishop d5 where the knight
has to go away and now it was up to Y to
decide if white wants to go somewhere
else with the knight right and sometimes
this is a problem being down upon from
blacks perspective if black doesn't have
a great way to keep up the initiative
white could easily be better in a lot of
these lines if I can finish development
and consolidate so I'm sure both players
were maybe not too disappointed with the
quick with the quick draw today so what
about game lag in Mira bellows against
Alejandro Ramirez 100 try something
interesting in the opening but I'm not
sure if you'd paid off yeah we should
take a glance of the opening because we
saw yes yesterday
Alejandro being very creative from early
on today same story he plays the very
unusual ecigs be six against a Queen's
pawn opening and the position seemed to
be very fresh within just a few moves
Pawnee for Bishop e7 f3 and d5 you don't
see this opening every day I actually
tried to play it once at the European
women championship but then I thought it
just too too passive and I decided not
to go for it afterwards that's right
probably at the the very highest levels
it can be considered a dubious opening
but at the same time it's somewhat of a
surprise weapon I'm sure
Bellus was not expecting this from
Alejandro and I do have some vague
memories of many years ago Hikaru
Nakamura playing some very similar lines
at
the US Championships from the black side
with his e 6b sex idea and karo if I
remember correctly one that won that
tournament I think it's very important
you know that sometimes players may not
go for the best line or the most trendy
line but if they prepare well and
understand what happened what's
happening in that position then maybe
the player the opponent doesn't know how
to react in the best way and that's how
the black and gained advantage here
that's right but if we see how the game
progressed it seemed like like white was
taking a lot of time in the opening but
found a very reasonable way of
continuing just very simply developing
the pieces focusing on I'm controlling
the center getting some initiative
against f7 pawn and I mean that the
position now the opening just looked
really Pleasant for whites pretty much
fully developed castled with the the
half open F file f7 is a long-term
target if we go forward Bishop takes e4
Queen takes e4 I mean the position just
appears to be more pleasant for whites
what is everything that he can wish for
the king is castled we have strong
Center but pieces are developed the
bishop has perfect spot to go to it's
black who he needs to solve how to
connect rooms how to get the bishop out
the night out white seems to be fine
right and black is still like it's
already moved 15 and this position black
still has the majority of the pieces on
the back ranked Alejandro is focusing on
expanding on the Queen side and maybe
creating some issues for this night
given the knight doesn't have too many
squares which prompted white to play the
move Bishop take the ADEs rook take b8
resulting in the pain against the rook
leaving the night safe on c3 for the
time being the game continued 'if I've
rook c8 94 Queen d5 white of course
wants to avoid the Queen trade given
that this King on g1 is much safer than
the King on Yeats white played the very
nice move Queen h3 taking advantage of
the geometry in this position attacking
the undefended rook on c8 black defended
with rook aids and then white went for
for even more aggression Knight g5
Bishop e7 was played and this brings us
to the current position who would you
prefer
Catherina wow I'm so surprised and I
think eight seven I mean it's a pawn up
but
these pawns can be so risky to take so
there's a move that happened in the game
night I get 700 I'd spend 8 minutes to
to decide but at the end he grabbed the
pawn and now he hopes to get the knight
back it's a moment and and beep on out
it's a very brave move I mean walking
into the pin but this move does have two
purposes for whites not only does it win
a pawn but it prevents block from
castling as it controls f8 square it
also I was about to say it there's a
threat of night at 6:00 but that's that
would be incorrect because the knight on
g6 defensive rook on h8 so but we can
improve on that and start with 94 and
then we have an ID f6 a huge threat
that's that's very tricky but I don't
know if Queen take d4 could be so we can
start with the rook 81 and prepare that
the thing is black really cannot Castle
short side because the knight is
covering the f8 square and black it with
either castlelong side because the Queen
on h3 is attacking to see a square so
white can't really wait white has time
to develop Ruby d1 and then threat to
have the thread with Knight f4 that's
actually very true it is clear what
white wants to do here just rook t1 with
neither for ideas and meanwhile it's not
entirely clear what Locke wants to do
given that I mean both King side and
queenside castling are illegal moves and
meanwhile I mean black wants to attack
the neither need 7 but it's just not
possible I move like neither fate would
walk into Knight f6 check so curious if
if black can go with something like
Queen e6 to block the Queen or try to
exchange the Queen because then the
knight is trapped and if the Queen moves
away then I can long castle a Queen e6
definitely a potential move yeah I would
be curious how how white response to
this may be the simple Queen h5 just
avoid the avoid any trades and keep the
pressure on and allow castle oh but this
does allow castling queenside that is
true
but the computer is not allowing me to
Castle queenside
I don't know if this is a bug in the
system the black already moved the King
all the requests move to remember Luke
takes unity so actually like is not
allowed to cast a long sighs Wow I come
this is why it helps to see that at the
earlier stage of the game this rook on
eight has moved a few times meaning
meaning this Queen e6 idea does not
actually allow black to Castle queenside
so maybe queen h5 would be a respectable
move yes wow that's so sad I wanted to
cast alongside so maybe a move like King
d7 at least try and connect the rooks
keep this rook a bit more defendant
there'd be an option or what if we just
go queenie six any way King D seven yes
sorry say that one more time yes I think
that's exactly what you mentioned so
Queenie six Kim D seven just to connect
the rooks really important to find
coronations coronation portal pieces
well certainly have to keep an eye on
this game I mean the the position after
Knight take h7 seems very critical and I
wouldn't be surprised if the players get
into time trouble very soon
given that there's so many complications
here let's see the females fight house
FF Abra Abraham Ian place against
Daenerys a Lukas hola I thought there
was an interesting opening ready for
some fights but now it seems the game
has progressed a lot since then the the
opening you would be familiar with
Katarina you you play the against
thoughts of Abraham Ian in the US
Women's Championship and if I'm not
mistaken you played the same line from
the lock side I played a little
different line but I actually played
this line for black and white so I have
a lot of experience with this and I
think it's a very interesting line for
black because there are options to play
for aggressive play but also to
transition to an endgame
that's right and if we look how the game
progressed it seemed like it was just a
standard opening accelerated dragon
position the the Bishop develops to d7
Tata gains space with f4 and the pieces
get traded but then at some point black
played the maybe
somewhat controversial pawnee 5 which
you don't see too often in the dragon I
mean the pawn on e5 does block the
bishop on g7 what do you make of this
move the goal is really to exchange some
pieces open some lines or open the
bishop on g7 because if you move back
with the bishop I can always trade on f4
and use the bishop on g7 to attack b2
that's true that this one g7 is is
usually a long-term peace and in such
middle team positions yeah there is
actually a very nice line that I thought
may be a little more comfortable for
awhile if we go back and instead of
playing a4 white can go just rook e1
with the idea to play 95 and then attack
the e7 just to play very strategically
yeah I'm sure you've you've studied this
position these positions before from the
white side and there are there are many
different plans going forward from from
the opening I note octave is a very
aggressive player and chose for chose
that this f4 idea may be going for a bit
more aggression let's see how the game
continued after Pawnee 597 was played
trade happened on c6 Bishop c3 keeping
initiative hitting the Queen on a5 Queen
c5 check King h1 and then the very
explosive pawn d5 just trying to bust
open the position and taking advantage
of the fact that the rook is aligned
with the Queen there's many central
targets and it seems like white is under
some major pressure here and also one
thing to note I remember when we saw
this game at this moment I think dinara
had like one hour 27 minutes still
unclogged so apparently she was in her
prep that's very possible
opening preparation play the role in
this game given that the Tata vis a
somewhat predictable player she plays a
lot of these open Sicilian positions and
you probably know this very well as you
can kind of choose which variation to go
into from the block side and I'm sure a
lot of these these dragon lines were
refreshed in Indian Aras mind before the
game started so if we see how the game
progressed e take d5 Pawnee for delaying
the cops around e5 hitting the Queen on
d3 Queen d4 played the Queen's got
traded and
I take t5 black is keeping initiative
exposing the bishop on g7 then taught to
play the maybe somewhat brave Bishop
take a seven grabbing the pawn far off
the board this is actually a trailer
ponds because Bach responded with Bishop
take b2 rook a b1 Bishop c3 and then a
very nice solidifying move from black
pawn at five oh sorry white played pawn
at five going for maybe a some some play
with this this open file for the rook
trying to maybe open up the position
further given that white does have the
bishop hair but what we can see also
nice position is that black is getting
some chances the bishop is open the
night is perfect the past pawn on e4
looks very dangerous this is something
that you want to get when you place it
Chilean so I think at that sense dinara
I think succeeded what you wanted to do
with her opening right and let's let's
zoom for it to the current position and
see how the play is developing it seemed
like black got a lot of initiative and
if we see this move Knight to e2 this is
a very nasty tactical shot attacking the
rook on c3 and threatening the fork on
g3 so this is this is a really nice
phoric idea which left white simply down
material after 93 King g1 white is down
the exchange for a pawn and it seems
like Tata vis as maybe falling apart in
this game the only good part about this
position is that the black pawns are
double dark squares so the bishop can be
attacking them so the King cannot just
advance and help the rook to to make
some some advances in this position it's
true but with with equal pawns and rook
versus bishop I would think that black
should be able to win this game without
too much difficulty but it is a question
like how does that block make progress
here
maybe the simple idea of something like
rook a one rook h1 this h3 pawn is is a
target it's on the light square it's
impossible for the bishop to defend and
it's not easy for the kingdom to defend
given that the king is on d3 and there
can be also some chances of actually
giving back the exchange and then being
faster at
taking back the pawn on d4 let's say if
I go and attack the pawn on h3 then the
king will be far away from the center
and this can be a huge disadvantage for
white and the endgame can be lost that's
true positions like this black always
wants to consider this this looming idea
of rook takes Bishop to go into a
winning King pawn ending so let's move
forward and take a look at at one of the
the key matchups for today
Geoffrey Zhong against received are
Bailey things are heating up even
further we glanced at this game a few
moves ago where Geoffrey played this
somewhat exotic Bishop to c8 receive
responded with Queens e8 very solid move
Geoffrey retreated Bishop a6 and it
seems like maybe the sieve could have
gone for some repetition with Queen a5
but instead it appears massif is playing
for a win he played Knight to be eights
hitting the Bishop Bishop b5 and then
the somewhat unexpected Bishop take h4 I
think that's just a thief sacrificing
and trying to play for some advantage
with some unequal material I like my
bishop take h4 because we get one pawn
if the pawn recaptures we get another
pawn then there is third point on b4 +
rook and Queen when they are attacking
the King there can be very dangerous
that's true but just black actually have
enough fuel for the attack in this
position I mean mishit a gauge for it
seems like the Queen would be the only
one attacking what would the point be
here for black rook takes d4 so rip take
t4 yeah rook take t4 is one threat but
also Queen g5 is another threat right
winning the rook on on c1 I think it's
interesting to know that the bishop on
b5 is kind of locked away together with
the knight on a 4 so that's something
that black and try to take advantage of
so I'm curious here what if white plays
a very calm rook d1 just getting the
rook on the defendant square defending
the pawn on e4 I mean that the knight on
b8 is just completely out of play but I
I may have been under attack things here
just taking the rook things B 5 and
Queen g4 ooh tactics are always fun in
these sort of situations where you can
try and calculate the the forcing
captures rook take d5
so pilling and after queen g4 king h2
you would like to take the rook or would
you like to fly Queen h4 check
I think Wesley would go here 45 show
because if I take the rook I lose the
night I don't know if he would take the
pawn it's actually true sometimes
positions like this it can be very
exciting and fun and then it just ends
in perpetual check but you know what I
think I would take the rook actually I
still feel the night is so off the port
and I have the pawns on the Kings side
that are very powerful we can remember
that's his game against Daniel Friedman
how he had similar pawns there and
walked in a wonder game that's true and
if the line continues Queen take t4 if
we count the pawns there black does have
three pawns for the knight and the queen
is very active White's Knight and queen
on b8 would be a bit out of play and
whites pawns kind of scattered across
the board they're all potential
weaknesses
maybe if I see if is playing for a win
here yeah the only thing you can do here
with the queen is to keep defending the
e5 and then I just marked with my pawns
g5h for g4 I mean there's nothing you
can do against that wow this is a very
interesting game it's true and if we
take a look the current position still
stands after Bishop take H for
Geoffrey's move both players at the
board they seem very very serious I'm
sure Jeffery calculating all of these
forcing lines may be seeing more than us
we'll have to keep an eye on this game
to see how it proceeds so what about the
game Renato my bias against the leader
I'll go beyond varoujan that's another
key matchup given that a Cobian is tied
for the lead here we have a more
strategical battle maybe not as exciting
as a Geoffrey Jean game with Queens off
the board looks like this position came
from some sort of Slav or Catalan
with-with-with both players may be
trying to maneuver their pieces and
optimize the position it seems like like
it's going to be a very long strategical
battle what do you think of the cover
Blanca
26 you always like to talk about that
I've been a Queen's pawn player for for
a long time and the knight on g6 is is
usually a nice piece that combines well
with the pawn structure especially the
pawns on e6 and d5 as a knight works
together to control some some key
central squares but we should note given
White's pawn formation the knight is
currently restricted in in many
different ways so even though the
Knights on d6 it's not that impressive
yet if white works a maybe place on bad
positional move like pawn d4 then I
could happily jump into e4 but I'm sure
why it will be very cautious advancing
any pawns forward without any good
reason and we have a game result in
Group B I'm not sure if we mentioned
that Daniel Freedman drew against the
Irish Arabic let's try and find that
game excuse me it's a group a group a
aha I don't think we talked about that
game though maybe we did touch on that
briefly we saw the kind of strategical
imbalance with black having two bishops
white having maybe a bit more central
space so maybe if you can go back to
that position before f6 I think that was
a key position for black two to know how
to react it's right white had just
expanded with a move f4 with with maybe
the somewhat enticing threat of a pawn e
5 to gain more space to kick the bishop
on g6 away and I do like the
prophylactic move from black playing f6
preventing White's threats and sometimes
in chess it's it's it's about preventing
your opponent's plans instead of going
through with your own plans f6 a very a
very nice stabilizing move and contrary
to what Ben Feingold always says this
catchphrase never play f6
I think f6 is a great move in this
position so if we go forward let's just
see how the game ended not sure if it
was repetition or a draw agreement
appears to be repetition the night
dancing back and forth between III and
d5 the bishop going back and forth
between d6 and e7 some quick draws today
and we have some tactics
in-game further Joshua against dragon
cameo I'm curious what is coming on the
leader of the group be going to do here
let me just find that game Josh free
Dell versus the tournament leader
Camille dragon Bishop d6 just played
interesting move given the queen is tied
down to the finding the rook the bishop
the bishop can't be taken if the bishop
has taken like just simply wins material
so black has to find find a reasonable
Square for the Queen it seems like there
are there are a few candidate moves to
consider between Queenie 8:28 and Queen
to see aids but most likely no matter
what you play I'm gonna exchange the
rooks and take on c5 that's right we
should point out Bishop d6 is a fork
given the pawn on c5 is also attacked
maybe the most logical move for a black
well I was gonna say is queen c8 but
that doesn't really help
rook take aids rook take aid Bishop
takes d5 we ready to run for a queen it
is equal material but these pawns
they're very hard to stop that's true
and sometimes positions like this you
even though it's equal material you want
to play for a win if you have the passed
pawn and especially the the Bishop
versus Knight scenario probably favors
white in this position given the bishop
can both maybe support the passed pawn
on the Queen side and control some key
squares on the Kings side so if that's
all for this game I think we have a nice
unfolding of the game like you
marabella's against a hundred Amira's i
think they went ahead with the idea we
were talking about with queen 86 and
King D 7 yeah let's just go back to that
moment when light captured on h7 because
yeah Queen e6 was played in Queen h5 and
King d7 let me just make sure that looks
like the right position rook a c1 King
c7 so instead of castling illegally on
the Queen on the Queen side black had to
kind of Castle manually get the King to
a safer place but having said that the
King does not seem that safe kind of
eyeing the rook on C
one it's usually a great idea if you can
put your rook on the same file as your
opponent's king especially in this case
as a file is half open but it looks like
the knight is locked on h7 it's it's a
free pawn but the night is out I still
don't know how to evaluate that move now
it's a very strange position and both
seen both sides seem a little bit stuck
on the Queen side given that I'm not
entirely sure what black is is doing in
this position we should point out
there's an interesting tactical idea
after White's last move Knight g3 the
knight is defending the Queen which
might allow the potential threat of
Knight g5 obviously that move can't be
played right away given its blacks move
but if we imagine Knight g5 rook take h5
why could have the intermezzo night take
e6 and perhaps kind of solve the
awkwardness of the Queen in the Knights
yes but I mean curious what if I play
rook a d8 so let's just this idea out
rook a d8 what if Knight g5 and now what
if I just move my Queen Queen d7 because
you have to also defend the night since
I'm attacking it with my bishop on e7
it's true so many things are being
attacked here the rook still attacking
the White Queen the Queen on g7 hitting
the d4 pawn and the bishop on e7 hitting
this Knight
this position is all about initiative
and I mean it seems like black would be
the one with initiative in the sign but
I mean the the craziness could continue
here if we could find a square for the
Queen also in the worst case scenario if
I don't like 27 what if I just captured
a knight on d5 and then capture with
rook on d4 I mean suddenly our pawn on
e5 is weak that's true White's position
could maybe crumble a bit quickly and we
should point out this King on c7 does
not seem safe but still the King on g1
is also potentially a big target given
the H file is half open
well hurry about this game what's gonna
happen here bu I hundreds only eight
minutes to figure out what to do here
and he still has 16 minutes before the
time control before he gets another 30
minutes that's right and these these
sort of positions I don't like to play
myself I like when the position is calm
there's clear positional concepts but at
the Grandmaster level sometimes you it
you have to deal with these positions
and that's why grandmasters they spend a
lot of time doing doing tactical
calculations doing very difficult
exercises to prepare themselves for
these types of situations we do have a
couple more moves right in this game and
Queen d5 was played followed by Knight
f5 so we were not predicting predicting
the next few moves and then Alejandro
responded with rook a e8 which brings us
to the current position has much changed
I mean there's still this that Silva's
pin at first glance I would probably
pick whites but it seems like it's gonna
be a very interesting tactical battle I
have to say that I liked it first time
of Queen d5 because I'm getting away
with the Queen so there are no tricks
with 95 but for example after more
Farooqi a that was that was played if I
take only 7 oh you can take with room
because d4 is hanging ok I was thinking
that there are still some tricks with
Knight f6 but actually it doesn't work
so maybe this is a nice chance for black
to to still keep the knight logged on 87
right and like white seems a bit tied
down here like the knight can't really
move the Queen is tied down to the night
this night is tied down to the thing the
d4 pawn so even though if black doesn't
maybe solve some issues right away it
might not be clear how White's
proceeding which makes a position just
very confusing for both sides and I want
to know that we are not using any
computer analysis only what we see at
the board so we don't know what's the
actual evaluation but if I was playing
this game practically I would pick black
what about you Eric I mean I would have
to pick whites
I heard that extra material and I like
the I like the fact this rook is on c1
staring down the light King but we we
have to keep in
my in that Bellis had a very slow start
to the tournament losing his first two
games he's going for blood in this game
it seems like he he's showing no fear
taking this pawn in he's seven and and
getting a very wild position finding the
next move I think this can be
challenging but let's see for a game of
checkers young against received or are
ballet because it unfolded exactly as we
predicted so now I'm just waiting for
the rook takes be a five right we see we
see that the Bishop was captured on h4
Queen to h4 rook t1 defending the steep
on it is a Massif smooth move and it
seems like he's he probably sees this
line with perpetual check and he's
wondering if he can go for four more in
the position and maybe he's calculating
whether to take the bishop immediately
after or start with a check queen g4
because forcing Queen exchange maybe not
not bad for a black at all and forcing
the King to already move may be an
interesting idea because white is not
forced to recapture there were gonna be
five that is true and we should point
out that Jeffries time is doodling I
mean he has less than four minutes left
and the see if is in the great position
where he could bail out for a draw or he
could try and place on some nuance moves
to try and keep trying prolong the game
and and put the pressure on Geoffrey who
who still has seven moves until more
time is added I would be very surprised
if Vasek played different move then rook
takes b5 or a queen g4 I think these are
the only moves in the position that's
right but it's very important when
you're playing just to at least identify
a couple options so you do have the
choice to make it's very possible that
these moves could transpose into one
another but it's at least important to
identify the differences between the
moves and what wide I mean massive has
enough time to do that but let's see
what's happening in the industry Husker
game because we were saying how the
pawns are going to march to where the
Queen and now the white pawns are marked
marching to are the king so this is
crazy I mean there's there's tons of
exciting games today we can see in jet
has continued with his kingside pawn
store him maybe Black has not gotten the
play that that he wanted on the the
queenside
and the focus is now shifting to two
blacks King Side pawn structure this
move f5 is looking to tear apart blacks
blacks shelter for the king who would
you prefer in this position I mean it
seems incredibly balanced I still feel
that the King Kong g2 is very weak and
the pawn is ready to promote so uh if I
just see this position I would just pick
back but we do have to calculate what's
gonna happen after F takes G six because
there can be dangerous there and there
can be perpetual at any moment that's
true and we should point out a move has
been played pawn c3 trying to shift the
focus back to the Queen side and
sometimes double-edged positions like
this you want to try and keep the focus
on the side of the board where you have
the active play in this case C 3 hits
the rook with tempo I'm sure we can
expect to move like rook c2 although
maybe the rook would be would not be so
happy on c2 being confined to passivity
rather than than going for apt to play
against the king side but we have to
keep in mind if the rook doesn't go to
c2 if it move like rook t6 is played
Bach is gonna score a touchdown on c1
yes I was looking at some variations
maybe pawn takes g6 to sacrifice the
rook oh that's uh that's pretty fun
takes rook Queen take h5 but the issue
is that the pawn on d4 on e4 is hanging
otherwise I would be okay with with
black trying to support a promotion on
d1 but Queen takes d4 that's the end
unfortunately the king is too exposed
and that's the problem with white
expanding all of the Kings side pawns it
does leave the King pretty naked on g2
and it's it's very possible in many of
these lines that the White King could be
a target that that gets attacked
so what about so probably White has to
play Roxy - that's your idea
I would think rook takes you - I'm sure
there's maybe some calculations with
fthe 6 but rook c2 seems necessary which
makes it seem like blacks should have
some upper hand here though there's
still the question how to deal with this
threat of of FTA g6
I am wondering if I can play instead of
rooks into rook a2 with the idea that
and at one moment I don't want Queen
takes e4 to be a four get the king and
rook I see what you mean and the rook is
more active on e2 as well and it does
control c2 so maybe it's not entirely
necessary for a white to blockade the
pawn and keep it on a slightly more
active Square but again fighters don't
have that much time they both have
around 10 minutes and they have to make
eight more moves before the time control
so we can expect crazy things happening
here that's right and we should go back
to the Geoffrey jean game because there
have some been some more developments
the line that we were discussing a long
time ago has actually played out on the
board
I assume black did take on b5 deflecting
the Queen from defending the rook on d1
and after after the dust settles King
Jiwon has been played both players seem
seem still focused on the game Geoffrey
has actually gained some time on the
clock he's above 4 minutes and now let's
receive smooth and the Cephas is
debating probably whether to take the
perpetual with a move like Queen g4 or
play for more my guess is he's gonna
play for more more now we can mention
that Vasa Fiza our former teammate at
spice team and we know how aggressive he
is now he always wants to win so I think
he's gonna play some h4 and try to win
because the night is still locked on a
for the Queen has to defend be 5 so
there is no reason for us to try to play
for a draw I think white is the one who
will try to find Perpetual with some
somehow getting the Queen to f6 although
it's it's just impossible I will say the
thief is not only aggressive in chess
he's so aggressive in soccer and
basketball even in ping-pong and he's
not he's not the type of person to be
competitive with and he takes his his
chest very seriously he goes by the
nickname the tiger so he's he's a
dangerous player and I can certainly
envision him playing for more here given
the the H plant is a passed pawn White's
pieces are out of play it probably makes
sense to try and prolong the game a bit
more and put the pressure on Jeffery
given that that white seems a bit tight
down the pawn on e5 is still weak along
with the pawn on b3 seems like black has
everything to play for
I think Jeffrey is in a very difficult
situation here I wouldn't want to play
this position for white and I wouldn't
want to play this against myself with
white I think this this is the tough
choose to drink but let's see what's
happening it came Jumma by F Renaud
against vara Cobian we have some new
moves here and that's another very
important matchup of today given var has
two out of two tied for the lead and it
still seems like a strategical battle
I'm not sure if too much has happened
since we last left there was a trade of
rooks on c8 but other than that the
structure hasn't really changed white
trying to optimize this night brings it
to f3 King g7 played brings us to the
current position I'm not too excited
about this game I don't know if there's
there's much to talk about it's very
possible that there will be developments
later but it seems relatively static
maybe we can mention the double pawn in
blacks position which is not not that
weak because it's controlling important
squares it's blocking white from
advancing on the Queen side and white
can apply anything like b3 or b4 because
the rook on a it would immediately
capture a bone on a3 so do double pawn
is actually stopping white from
advancing and when we see the that white
has pair of bishops of course white
wants to open up the position but it's
just not clear how to do that that's
right and we should keep in mind that's
a good point about the double pawns
double pawns are not always a bad thing
in chess while they they can sometimes
be weak they do create more open files
in this position if we know this Black
has both the half open a file
and the open sea file while white can
only try and utilize the open sea file
so so the double pawns probably give
some gonna fit for black given that they
can't easily be attacked by whites yes
but you're not so excited about the game
so let's move on I think interesting new
moves we have in game image against
Peter Prohaska Alexander is actually
going for some tricks as I wanted to
sacrificing the rook and but I'm not
sure if is actually if it works and
that's group a correct correct yes Wow
so rook c2 was played and yeah the
position is opening up that players are
getting lower on time let's go back to
after c3 rook see to played G take f5
which really just destroys the plan
structure for black leaves upon an h5
hanging white seemingly very happily
took on h5 and now there's some mating
ideas with rook h6 looming there is also
the idea that if Queen takes e4
I can move the king let's say h3
actually I just we probably not let's
say g1 the idea is that if you take the
rook immediately I can have perpetual or
just by playing her Ruby g6 draining it
off and there's no way how you can get
away with this this might be the theme
of the days and crazy some crazy attacks
liquidating into perpetual check it's
not the the most exciting finale but
it's it's a common occurrence among
these these incredibly sharp positions
especially where where the Kings are
weak and I wouldn't be surprised if
either white or black barrels out with
some sort of Perpetual check but when I
now look at it a little deeper
I'm curious what's gonna happen after
Queen takes e4 probably queen kim jiwon
and something like rook c6 just trying
to avoid the perpetual check my
perpetual check it's an interesting idea
so you're saying that maybe black has
some play for for a win here at rook c6
preventing rough g6 maybe going for the
trade of rooks and we can see that that
blacks king is being kept safe for the
time being White's Kings still very
naked on on on g1 that's all about that
you know some g6 white
right now g6 going all out I can even
sacrifice the rook like black and go
ahead and go Queen d4 to capture the
rook on f6 but there is checkmate after
so Queen d4 let's say I move the King
King h1u Queen takes f6 and I have
amazing h7 it doesn't care it doesn't
matter how much material you're down
techne it ends the game so g6 is a
pretty creative move I would be curious
after g6 come back get away with taking
so if you take now I can recapture with
Queen and I'm checkmating you after King
h8 and rook takes FH
ah takeoff it actually didn't see that
move right away but that yeah that just
ends the game so so maybe black would
have to bail out somewhere I mean black
is free to go for perpetual at any
moment I think after Queen takes e4 kim
jiwon if I go King III instead of
playing rogue c6 I'm sorry I think Roxy
success so let's go back to the current
position so you're saying we're saying
Queen take e4 here King g1
so maybe not rook c6 immediately maybe
not maybe just give another check
somewhere III d4 yeah I mean if act
really wants to draw you can always take
on c2 and make white fill out with a
perpetual so both sides have similar
ideas trying to maybe just be safe and
force other side too to give perpetual
so we'll definitely keep an eye on this
game because the times are dwindling but
there are a good number of players in
time trouble a game that catches my eye
is as a battle between Tata of Abraham
Ian and dinara saduak Asafa which seems
just about over
given the pawn on g2 is as about two
Queen and some plan like rook h1 and g1
Queen just seems unstoppable
unfortunately I think this game won't
have any more moves I think the game is
over because I can always help the
rookin helped upon to promote so if
something like Bishop g1 happens I can
just play rook h1
yeah at the shishi one doesn't solve
anything I'm wondering can white try and
create some last chances if we go to the
current position with a move like
bishops they got six well then I go King
f8 and even after Bishop e7 I go King I
ate well I wouldn't want to play Bishop
to d4 in this position try and perhaps
sacrifice a bishop for the pawn and race
race the passed pawns down the board I
think the problem with this is all the
pawns are separated meaning that they
can just be taken off the board very
easy and I can just take it immediately
rook takes c3
I don't know ever take c3 is a very nice
move the Irish take c3 and the King wall
very easy defend against these passed
pawns yeah this is just seems over for
frittata but let's see what's happening
in the game
bellows radomir against Alejandra
Ramirez there were so many moves played
the position has transformed a ton since
we last looked at it when we did last
look the night was still on h7 and and
the Queen was on h5 let's go back to the
position see how it actually developed
going forward here at Queen d5 Knight f5
rook a e8 very scary looking move Knight
d6 just going into the heart of blacks
territory
perhaps targeting this this pawn enough
7 but we should note that the knight is
not sufficiently defended on d6 in the
pawn is undefended on d4 so black
happily took on d4 with check king h1
bishop take d 6e take d6 and then
instead of taking the pawn black played
the somewhat peculiar King and b6 I
think this is because White's Queen
could could swing across the board and
in capitalize on the undefended a5 fun
yeah sometimes the material is not the
main focus it's really of the king but
what's happening so then rook everyone
I'm very impressed with the way white is
playing this I see making use of the
geometry of the board white has kind of
defended the past D pawn Queen f3
hitting the pawn in c6 Fon c5
d7 keeping the initiative
it seems like things have gone very
badly for alejandro yes I don't like how
it unfolded and it's incredible to see
how the night on 87 is kind of awkward
but it's still a night so if you never
take it I would just go back and at one
point and I will have a fresh piece
whereas the pawn on d6 is just running
for a queen now we should see what
happened because after rook take h7 it
appears that white could take the rook
and promote to a queen but we have to
keep in mind there's a main threat on
the board h2 is is currently attacked
with mates which provokes volley
Mirabella to play the move pawn to g3
and this is a current position black
black to move black is temporarily up a
piece but the menacing pawn on g7 what
to make of this position I mean who
would you prefer I don't like it for
black because I have to move the rook to
d8 that's the very logical continuation
and then I have something like rook defy
for white I'm attacking the pawn I'm
forcing the Queen away and I'm
threatening with Ruby d6 and checkmate
it's true we can see Alejandra is
sitting at the board and Vladimir Bellis
is just up and walking around with with
five minutes just over five minutes on
the clock i I just envisioned just based
on on the the video up there that
Alejandro can't be too happy with what's
unfolded yeah and I think he had some
good chances there but it's very
difficult to make the correct moves when
you have a little time on your clock so
even grandmasters can make mistakes and
get into that position but let's see if
he figures out how to get away with this
yeah let's move on to to another game
seems like a lot of games are unfolding
very quickly it's gonna be hard to keep
up with all of the games I should note
for the viewers if you want to see the
games on your own go to us chess champs
calm you can follow along and see all
the action and I mean there's there's a
lot of exciting games today
let's go on - what's he building Jeffrey
Jean yeah against the thief the thief is
clearly playing for a win
having snagged the pawn on e5 if we go
back to the position that we where we
last lost last left off kingi one was
played pawn h4 queen b5 giving up the e5
pawn to try and bring back the Queen
into the game of a thief gladly capture
the pawn queen d3 d4 black has two -
very nice looking passed pawns about to
run down the board night b2 played queen
g5 check Geoffrey's move and we should
keep in mind that Queen g5 is move 40 so
both players received an extra half hour
on the clock I'm sure that the pace of
the game will slow down and Geoffrey
will maybe take some more time here to
figure out what's going on and there are
two more moves that were played king h2
and queen a for the one good thing is
that the night is getting back to the
game from h4 to be - maybe to c4 but
there are so many black pawns to be
attacking the King so I'm not sure if
the night will be ready to stop all of
them no look at this this menacing wall
of pawns just and it's so easy to play
back in this position because it's
really just a matter of of pushing pawns
keeping things defended meanwhile white
house to figure out how to coordinate
the Queen and the Knights and this does
not look fun five pawns especially
against this lone one pawn majority have
to put my money on the sieve I will do
the same and we should keep in mind if a
thief wins this game it's a it's a three
out of three starts can't do much better
than that that would be amazing
especially since he is still not done
with his school he's doing his research
projects and he's playing amazingly but
let's see what's happening in the index
Prohaska game because that I feel is a
very exciting game a lot of tactics and
strategy that things is happening there
yeah we can see a few more moves have
been played out Queen h2 played and it's
White's move is black getting away with
with winning the rook on c2
let's see how this actually happened so
Queen techie four was played and then
King f1 which we were looking at King g1
earlier King f1 allows the Queen H h1
check forcing the king up the board and
then Queen h2 it seems like a simple
skewer well but we have to know that if
you take the rook remember there is
still worth g6 that's right I guess only
36 seconds to decide if he's gonna take
the rook and then go for the perpetual
or he is trying to play on that's right
I assume King f1 was played and now it
is blacks move seems like the players
might be going for a perpetual we can
see players unfolding very rapidly both
players not wasting too much time
it seems like we probably are witnessing
the perpetual check yes so let's go back
to the game of bells Vladimir and I had
Ramirez we have many moves there and it
looks very interesting so that that game
is in Group B we have we have the White
King walking up the board King h3 just
played I am a bit curious how this
happened it seemed somewhat favorable
for whites we are worried about the road
e5 and he just thought I wonder if this
is a Miss tactic or if it was all
calculated by Bellis but it seems like a
pretty direct combination after King
take H to Queen take B to this rook on
c1 is attacked the question is can black
actually get away with taking the rook
and I think the answer is no is it no
after Queen takes c1 rook t6 can the
King Highland on a 7 this is a bit
remain in the worst case scenario I
always have Luke a six and queen c6
perpetual I was about to say this is
very reminiscent of the the in judge
Prohaska game as one side could bail out
with a perpetual check somewhat of an
unexpected theme for today let's just
show this on the board broke a six just
one potential line where it appears
white just has per
so check here maybe even more actually
we might have to say I'm looking if I
have more but I have to keep in mind
that black has some chances since the H
file is open now so Rukia trade can be a
threat and maybe it can be black who is
going for some checkmate yeah especially
if if white gets a little bit careless
I mean if white wants to play on for a
win you probably at some point have to
take the rook but then you allow many
checks from black and at the very least
black will have perpetual if not more in
this position let's go back and we'll
say on this game because Alejandro's
time is ticking down he has one minute
left to five minutes for out for
Vladimir Bellis they have five moves to
make time control so any would you take
the rook on c1 or would you maybe be
considering something like rook rook h8
seems like a few choices to consider
here yeah I'm looking at rook h8 or
night if for some tactics but what is
just doing fine because after any
exchange we have to keep in mind that
the pawn on g7 is ready to be promoted
so I think the safest way is to capture
the rookin and hopefully doesn't have
anything more than perpetual but we have
a move a hundred ninety five which we
were not predicting ninety five seems
like a very bold move hitting the Queen
bringing the night towards the center
where perhaps and I could play a role in
some defense as well as offense and we
should note that the knight takes away
the very key square on g4 so if I'm not
mistaken rook h8 is a main threats yes
and also we don't have the perpetual
right now because the night is defending
c6 square so after rooty six and king a7
we cannot play rook a7 row casings
hoping for a perpetual because Queen
cannot get to the camp due to the knight
defending c6 that's very true I really
like this move 95 Alejandro played it
without too much time on the clock and
we can see now if Lavin Mirabella is
thinking with his hand I'm brushing
through his hair he looks to the under
stress yeah but he has four minutes so
that's a lot of time to understand the
position and see what's happening so
let's see if we can understand it here
what you do with Whitesell rook h8 it's
a threat
I have check on these six what are other
moves that I can do here I'm just in awe
with this Nagi five move it's doing so
many things at once it's threatening
mate it's attacking whites Queen it's
stopping this perpetual check idea I
mean I I would be very scared as whites
what can you can you maybe bail out with
Brooke taking five but that doesn't seem
too promising rook taking five just
Queen to e5 and we should keep in mind
black has has extra material and e7
could be very easily falling in many
lines wow this is amazing look 95 and
Vladimir Bella's still kind of playing
around with his hair you can sometimes
tell when players are nervous or not too
comfortable they start fidgeting around
especially in in time control Bellus has
less than three minutes and in 30
seconds left still what five moves to be
played until time control I wouldn't be
surprised if the game is decisive before
they hit move move 14 yeah I mean 95 is
a fascinating move so let's give our
team you know three minutes to think
what's gonna play the move he's played
rook d6 check very forcing move
Alejandro has now two logical options
between king c7 and king a7 we were
talking about king a7 earlier we didn't
really consider this move king c7 which
has been played hitting the rook on c6
prostrate pressuring the pawn on d7 now
it seems like everything is going wrong
for a white given that that the rook is
now attacked the Queen is still attacked
and there's a made threats still on h8
what to do for for whites I think
Alejandro may be walking with a point
today though we should note the pawn on
c5 is hanging and this this is a type of
physician and engine will crunch through
very quickly but for us near humans we
have to maybe investigate the key lines
let's investigate this move rook takes
e5 because it could lead to some some
immediate raids just to note also for
our viewers we have our
Tata Abraham Ian unfortunately lost to
Daenerys adieu acasola
so that's right in that game was was
expected for frittata to go down tough
result frittata having a very long fight
yesterday falling apart and what should
have been a drawn end game losing today
she'll have to regroup in and try and
eat disciplined and then fight back for
the later rounds that's what we have to
remember these players they really fight
every day yesterday she had like 500
game I believe so then to fight another
one to the next day and be ready to do
your best it is very difficult but
hopefully we have still six rounds to go
and there are a lot of points to grab
that's right it takes a lot of like
physical and mental stamina to play
these very long games of chess and and
also you just need to get a lot of sleep
too I mean don't don't stay up too late
go to bed early and and focus on some of
the external factors that that can
influence your performance during the
game and we will have a guest in the
studio so we will take a short break and
be back with you a moment comes in chess
when you need to test yourself at a
different level chess 24 premium offers
the tools that you need to reach your
maximum potential from hundreds of
interactive video lessons to becoming
part of the chess 24 community you can
analyze with friends or coach your
students live you get twenty four by
seven coverage of chest news and events
access to premium analysis and
commentary and the chance to interact
with grandmasters and other top players
and coaches get it bashed from the best
and even challenge them to a battle be
the best chess player you can be it's
time to level up your game with just 24
Premium Membership
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
this August the best chess players in
the world are coming to st. Louis with a
grand chest tour
st. Louis rapid and blitz and
Sinquefield Cup tournaments will feature
the world's best right here in st. Louis
st. Louis Chess Club is celebrating its
10th anniversary and these tournaments
will be a highlight you won't want to
miss for tickets and more information go
to st. Louis chess club org
hello everyone welcome back in studio
iron women prayer master Catriona me
Java and I have here a special guest the
International master from Kazakhstan
Dena Rosario akazawa
welcome thank you I know you are a new
here in this place is this your first
time in San Luis playing the tournament
yeah actually it's not also the first
time in centuries but that was the first
time in years safer oh and how do you
like it how do you like this place how
do you like United States well I think
it's great
everything is great special
accommodation and the tournament hall
and even the snake work everything is so
perfect I really like this tournament
perfectly I'm happy you enjoyed so let's
look at the game what are the key
moments you played Sicilian was that
your preparation for this game yeah
actually I prepared this variation and
so we have a server game yeah a soccer
game and from just like so yeah that was
my preparation until the move like yeah
oh wow so the preparation was ready we
were mouthing during the analysis that I
believe here you had like one hour 27
minutes oh wow okay so it was is that
are you copying anyone's games or is
that a new game that you just prepped at
home I think it's a new game
I just prepared yeah because here she
played a five before and her opponent
had advantage after GE e and then just
so you saw this game yeah it takes and
just now at age five after Fe yeah I
think it's bigger than fish for yeah
because this pawn can be weakness we
support we see them all pieces that are
kind of attacking having perfect spots
so tetap did not repeat that variation
yeah I think she planned variation and
that was my preparation now she has I
think Fe or Knight of 6 I don't know
what what is back to her actually now
what was your idea with E 5 no we were
thinking about it in the studio if you
want to open the bishop or crush the
center what is the key idea of this the
key idea is just I just want to crush a
central mm-hmm and just I also want to
open my bishops also so so 9797 yeah
King h8 I take 3 6 we take c6 Bishop
c3 bishops is 3 Queen c5 I mean the
position looks like black is totally
fine your pieces are having perfect
cooperation you have the center the only
drawback can be the pair of bishop that
white has but it's unclear how valuable
that pair of bishop will be yeah I think
it's slightly better for black actually
Oh already okay so what happens so maybe
she needs to play Bishop e5 instead of
ET I'm not sure mm-hmm
I prepared the Bishop e5 and did you
plan to take it for now I saw that I
will
play 94 yeah so did this may go into
some oh you have a friend yeah
threat and also the white Bishop isn't
so good so maybe I cannot do that so if
I go back okay so there are some threats
so let's see what happened in the game
so he takes d5 f or I think that if she
played sorry Bishop deform mhm
then I could play 25 oh wow so you are
not worrying about being captured
because you are also attacking her Queen
yeah so she liked windy for she willing
to go for trades maybe some endgame and
maybe the key moment was here because
Bishop a7 I didn't like this one I think
we thought it it's a little risky yeah
it's it's a risky so so you would take
on g7 instead yeah taking on g7 King g7
and maybe here just to play okay do you
wanna it looks very natural move now
this does look scary for a practical
game but it's not maybe such a big issue
because yes trade take taken just rookie
one rookie won and suddenly denied has
to do something has to go back this pawn
can be weak to probably neither for now
we cannot take immediately yeah but just
King gauge to I think it's okay this for
right sorry
so maybe it's better for black to play
just a five instead of 93 and they think
also it's it's fine
well it's not a big advantage it's more
look like spec well mm-hm
but that should the goal for black you
want to equalize and then have two
chances to push so that I've took on a 7
rather risky move so I should be - it
could be one maybe here is better to
play a rock 81 but then I will play a 5
and looks like it's better
okay so rookie b1 bishops III f5 well
that's an interesting move to cannot
allow you to make the loop on chain on
the other hand it's losing some tempo
and giving you some space
yeah and also I have maybe something
like ninety four after g5 in separations
so so did you feel comfortable in this
position already or how did you during
your game yeah
in this position I feel very comfortable
mm-hmm so you had also time advantage
which helps you at least psychologically
if not chess wise course so here I said
maybe it's it's also fun to play Bishop
d2 okay I saw that if neither four is
winning exchange then I should play
I also calculated look at floor GF know
that she would sacrifice me here g4
rooks history or rubgy to Bishop f 3e to
bishop sorry bishop F to you one Bishop
you one rook e1 English and in this
position I saw rookies three and I think
it's winning so your so you think that
white could try this in order to try to
build a fortress but then there is this
theorem of rookie three which
unfortunately attacks the bishop because
we have to keep in mind that the pawn is
paint and attacks the rook and whenever
there is a trade that's pretty much a
given
yeah right so yeah I've created a
desperation is so good okay I can play a
94 mm-hmm so instead she took on c3 and
now you are an exchange up and it looks
like an easy win yeah but then I think I
made some mistake here okay
so this was a plate I went after the H
yeah and here I don't know who I play as
if I'd actually well I should play what
do you think it's a better move
18:07 kick himself and after King six is
just age five
yeah so you don't want to allow the King
to kind of get closer I think
Grandmaster devorah's he always said
that I could bodycheck not to allow the
King to get closer so yeah
c5 was it's not so big mistake I still
have a winning position but well it's
not so easy
king of seven so kick Nancy five and
then H five but it still looks like like
he's going for me yeah but do you think
why little we have improved somewhere
well yeah she play it good move King d5
and it's still winning I think but here
I think I shouldn't play King it's
because after Bishop d4 rooks is three
alginates is Bishop D for a ROC three
have six I think it's a little bit risky
for a black oh yeah why we are actually
doing for promotion but after King f8 it
looks like everything safe after King f8
its mm-hmm well congratulations for a
nice game and I have a couple of
questions I know you from we play that
in three games that were junior all
inferior world teams I'm curious about
the chess in Kazakhstan because you
happen to have a very strong team in
these events and I do limpid I think you
grab the second spot at one moment
actually we took six place or the
ability hmm so how is chess developing
in a Kazakhstan well now it's time
consistent chest is developing so I mean
we have many champions in the u.s.
categories and also our team men and
women also we're I think we're showing
good game good games so what's more
important that I think we are trying to
do our best and we are hoping to show
the good results on the next link yes
absolutely you have huge chances with
your strong team and last question are
you a professional chess player are you
a student what is your situation right
now well I think first of all I'm a
professional chess player and then I'm a
student
Oh also for me a chess is more important
perfect well congratulation I hope
you're going to enjoy your time in this
tournament in st. Louis and good luck
for the rest of you to remain K somewhat
and we will have a short break with
another special guest this is a crucial
situation in this game Metheny must make
a move but what will it be all eyes are
on Matheny to make a move a lot easier
if you weren't doing that right next to
me it doesn't bother me check
the st. Louis chess club celebrating 10
years of promoting teaching and playing
the game of chess visit the st. Louis
chess club and help celebrate our 10th
anniversary there's a weekend vacation
on be surprised be intrigued be
delighted the world chess Hall of Fame
in st. Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
this August the best chess players in
the world are coming to st. Louis for
the grand chess tour
st. Louis rapid and blitz and
Sinquefield Cup tournaments will feature
the world's best right here in st. Louis
st. Louis chess club's celebrating its
10th anniversary and these tournaments
will be a highlight you won't want to
miss for tickets and more information go
to st. Louis chess club org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everyone to the 2018 summer
chess classic I am here joined by
Grandmaster Alejandro Ramirez after a
very heartfelt exciting tactical
tactical game how do you feel right now
uh well I'm happy that I want but
obviously the game can't be called high
quality so I mean I'm okay
but I'm very happy that I won it was
really a very suspicious game but you
know I witness I win
sure take us through it I was wondering
what inspired this somewhat unusual East
6 b 6 and the opening is something
you've played before
yeah actually played this before a few
times I played it and against crush I
got killed against crush once I played
it a few other times it's part of my
repertoire
it's nothing too special okay but f3 is
actually super unusual the main lines
are Knight c3 and Bishop d3 obviously
somehow depending upon you for mm-hmm
and okay Knight c3 Bishop before there's
a ton of games like that it should be
three there's a bunch of variations I
mean a5 can be considered but I think it
doesn't work 96 and there's other lines
so we were you out of preparation after
f3
yeah well preparation is a strong word
yeah lame my knowledge of f3 was
non-existent so how do you feel after
the position resulting from the opening
it seemed like the the position seemed a
lot more pleasant for wife yeah I feel
like I forgot how to play chess right I
mean this is ridiculous what I did going
back I mean even going for you just go
back to d5 honestly it's just a terrible
move I had the feeling that after d5 I
should he should take on the fattest Lee
Edie and then I thought he was gonna go
eat five I think I was trying to make a
little bit clever trying to I was trying
to figure out how to have an advantage
of having the bishop on a fader than
item b1 because you can reach the
position after f3 after a bishop a 93
Bishop before f3 or just I know that
line I see but here I mean I thought I
could play f6 on okay there's a lot of
garbage but it doesn't
it's not really relevant but the idea of
the 93 you can just keep the center of
life completely eluded me and the reason
is that after half takes e4 I forgot
that if I play Knight f6 I thought he
had to do something super awkward but
this is where I'm saying like I forgot
to play chess yeah he just plays Bishop
d3 and defense the pawn and I honestly
can't take on d4 Ravi's yeah obviously
you can never take one d4 because we
should be 5 check when it's a queen and
I kind of forgot about this when I was
looking at d5 and I'm fortunate and then
I was just position I'm like oh my god
he's just gonna get a strong Center and
I have no way to deal with it so I
thought ok what kind of setup do I win
against it
probably at some point I should go
something like c5 and force issues but I
didn't because you know bad players do
bad things and he played Queen b3 and
then after Queenie sound I was so
confused about him what he was doing
because I analyzed this variation matter
of matter of 3 96-95 and then there's
Knight a5 and then there's some check
that doesn't work so check is dangerous
I cannot go net if I gotta have this
nice move instead of 985 they just log
castle mmm just give up the pawn you
don't really give up on actually there's
no real good way to take it you take it
with the bishop I take on d4 with the
night mm-hmm and if you take on f7 with
the night I go Knight a5 and you cannot
protect this bishop on c4 with the Queen
that's true yeah it seems like a a nice
line for black yeah this was would have
been really nice but obviously he just
plays Knight G - I'm not gonna say place
my G - I'm I realize how much trouble
I'm in vision basic is probably forced
the position did not seem too impressive
just in terms of angles terrible
developing your pieces and controlling
the center seems both with like things
White has done perfectly yeah you can't
show this to students because black one
at the end and I kind of got rewarded
for playing badly so you shouldn't show
this to too many people but okay
the problem is a Bishop takes Queen
takes and I thought okay I'm not doing
so bad I thought okay play knight c6 I
develop my pieces and I should be okay
but 96 just loses to rook takes f7 ouch
so Apple tactics simple tactics so I
realized after at this point that I
cannot develop any of my pieces the
bishop can come out anyway
because specialty 65 mm-hmm Misha piece
is just probably illegal and I mean I
cannot move my night so I actually can't
move anything
so I played c6 and such a depressing
this is a depressing position so
everything here for the next few moves
is completely depressing I have to go
for something like this I don't know if
this was the best he could do mm-hmm but
probably some other alternatives so at
what point did you feel like the game
was maybe swaying in your favor where he
wasn't so this next move actually he
played was really bad creation you're
okay and I'm sure that he has someone
that kind of moved I don't know what it
is but even just keeping the tension of
something like night instead of 95 93 in
the night f5 it's probably very
dangerous there's probably millions
moves here that are very strong I'm sure
there's some kind of sacrifice also but
95 was really about I think he missed
this idea of it should be 7 and if it
takes one f7 with the night I cancel
it's very tricky and castling is a legal
move yeah
so don't you forget that because they
were accept package and then but it is
completely legal and I think he's just
doing terribly mm-hmm and what he did
was also very suspicious night takes h7
and now the problem is that we were both
in like severe time pressure I had like
16 minutes left and we're on with like
21
that's tough especially when you have
such a disastrous opening you spend so
much time trying to solve the problems
and then you don't have any time left
yeah so is that a pretty six I think
that h4 was a better move but okay at
this complicated analysis and then I was
told that you guys for eternal alone
Castle which is kind of funny that's
right we we did not acknowledge that it
would like so many times yeah of course
if you just see the position then long
castles very strong because now you
connect the rook the rook king goes
directly to be summon exactly and the
night on h7 is really about but I can't
unfortunately so King decently said his
best try yeah and this is I don't know
what I don't believe in my position but
you know whatever I did what I have to
do I mean it seems like the type of
position that's complicated enough
especially at the time situation where
there are chances for both sides given
the awkwardness of light with the now e7
no I mean this is what I'm hanging on
through
that he can't do anything exactly he has
so many resources but I did not see this
with 96 at all and I'm still very
confused about it even - like - right
now I mean at first we were impressed
with this move that he can get a pawn on
d6 and support with the rook but it's
actually clear no I mean I saw it yeah
okay this is nice
Thanks and here actually even the move
Queen takes T sixes did not seem so
clear to me I give up
85 which is to check which looks
terrible and I go King v8 or even King
b7 I'm not short party can be sounds
better
rook f7 and then rookie seven and you
would think that this is like almost
losing four black somehow if I can hold
on there's always a there's a counter
play I'm only down one pawn the knight
on HSN is not playing he has problems
with h2 with the knight on HSN with the
back rank it's surprisingly not so clear
probably instead of rook takes f7 much
better as to just play route d1 rook F
d1 and now that here I wasn't so sure
where to put the Queen and this is what
scared me out of the variation I see
which is probably correct that probably
should not go for this so I go King b6
which I thought was on the move d1
goshawk Queen e5 is only move because if
I play the Queen anywhere else he has
this idea of rooks t6 check and queen d5
mate I would just sum of like Queen f2
is just yeah disastrous for black that's
some nice checkmate it's a nice
checkmate but I didn't want to get
checkmated of course some Queen e5
yeah and now Queenie f3 seems forced I
don't know where else I mean he cannot
really go into any of the end games
because if it takes 25 I take with the
rook and he solves the HTTP problem but
ignited still trapped I see
so Queen f3 is fine c5 is fine and here
I just didn't know what's going on d7
okay I win a temple with rook takes h7 I
might as well play that and we're both
down to like five minutes so we have no
time but this means g3 surprised me so
much why would you ever play g3 where
you can play h3 mmm and what's the
difference well what happened in the
game basically but on h3 obviously he
also has some problems for example if I
go rogue d8
I mean there are so many variations in
which one once the Queen leaves I can
take on h3
and for supper petrol that's right we
were predicting that at at some point a
perpetual might come about either for
him or for you yeah yeah it's actually
very unclear and but to be honest I mean
me and Katharina really had no idea what
was going on I mean you guys probably
knew better than me because I was like I
my mine was almost shut down I was so
tired
mm-hmm d8 so at what point were you
confident that you were actually winning
the game so I did okay so this is what
happened rectifier rook takes h2 and
this is why g3 is bad because it allows
moon takes h2 queen tanks and I saw all
this and okay at this point I have three
minutes and I spent two minutes and 40
seconds on this move so I see that Queen
c1 is a draw because Queen see one rogue
d6 king a salmon forced
rook a six and we like we were looking
at this exact line exactly that's just a
perpetual but I was like okay figure out
if I have something stronger and then I
saw 95 which looks like an incredible
move but I couldn't find a defense for
him I'm threatening checkmate that's the
big threat and we were praising the
smooth given you're attacking the Queen
you're threatening yet you're defending
some key squares on he squares that's
also very important Knight comes back to
the game and see what's always hanging
and I actually did not find a defense
for him so you know with 20 seconds I
was like okay thanks I such a difficult
move for white to deal with yeah I'm
trouble and III still don't think he has
a difference I haven't checked it with
the computer but I don't know what he
can do and we haven't checked it with
the engine either so I'll have to I'm
sure you'll you'll go on to be like plus
10 or something less punches through the
position but I actually have no idea and
here after 95 I felt really good because
I couldn't see a difference for him and
when he played d6 I thought okay this is
my first intention like it the first
thing I looked at and it looks kind of
clever because if now I go King a7 which
is the more logical move now most of the
variations like Queen h5 for example
Queen takes c1 Queen takes of five like
this is actually probably not possible
to win because study the point of d7 is
huge making is very weak I'm probably
have a perpetual yeah I'm not even sure
I have that but I probably do but that's
probably all I get
but King c7 is just crushing because it
looks like super dangerous
but but the rats attack the Queens
attack everything is hanging fancy 6 is
importantly defended because in many
variations route t6 was an issue uh-huh
and I could never go King c7 so you
almost put it out of your mind
right because you can aragaki-san
because Music's was mate but now the
knight on e5 protects c6 that's true
it's beautiful finish on that you're
basically attacking everything in whites
position yeah somehow and yeah this is
just lost because he has to go into this
lost rook endgame which he didn't but
it's just quickly lost anyways takes
takes and he said screen defy King e7
and you have to trade obviously I mean
rooks it's losing but even if he does
trade I mean it's uh yeah I'd really
live I mean I'm only up one pawn but the
difference in the King activity is
humongous that's true so I take one d7
taken a five and I think after rugby aid
mm-hmm well it takes a 95 first take on
a five yeah yeah I think it should just
be winning surely with the rook uh very
well supporting your pass beep on
yeah I'm especially the King proximity
compared to his right I mean if this
King is so bad and I'm still up upon
should be just one right well
congratulations after probably stressful
game today
do you know who you play tomorrow I play
my student I'm playing uh Jamila John
mm-hmm so what sort of psychology do you
have going into that game well I've done
a couple times already and uh I beat him
I think once in one of these classic
series mhm
so I mean I know my students pretty well
it's always tough to prepare because we
can't go into something they already
analyzed that's very true so I'll just
play some game I see what happens and I
do have to ask you you you did Spanish
commentary in the same studio yeah
during the the US Championships do you
feel like doing commentary helped you or
help you with your game going into a
tournament like this I'm not sure it
really helps but it's nice to be active
to consistently be looking at chess to
consistently be analyzing variation
especially because I do my own analysis
without engines so I'm always forced to
analyze so I would I don't know if it's
necessarily that good but it keeps me
sharp and at least I think that because
I've been looking at dress I can find
things like 95 which otherwise I think I
would just go for the draw was gonna
take c1 that's true it's not an easy
task to find 95 under is such a severe
time pressure yeah well congratulations
I'll let you go best of luck throughout
the tournament well thank you so much
you're welcome
moving on we have we have a very intense
battle taking place between Jeffrey
Zhang and the Seif Terra Bailey we see
them on screen a very complex position
to if we go to that game we can see the
position has transformed a ton since we
last less last left off let's actually
see how the game game proceeded we saw
the Seif had a good number of pawns for
for Jeffrey's northern Queen which would
seem like a very favorable imbalance
variable material imbalance for for the
black side after after Wasif turned down
any perpetual check opportunities pawn
h4 was played and let's zoom forward to
the current position for black who is
just a matter of pushing pawns and and
especially optimizing the square for the
Queen and afteri 5 we can see blacks
pawns are looking incredibly menacing
very nice kind of mini pawn chain here
we can expect moves to be played very
soon like pawn on f5 and let's zoom
forward even further
there's a nice kind of pocket of safety
for the king I see Queens do we're
trading on g4 after F take g4 it's now a
knight and two pawns
versus one two three four five six pawns
for black very big imbalance I'm joined
now by Katarina who is back let's get to
the current position any thoughts about
what's happening here after the the
current position F take g4 let me just
refresh my computer to have the crate I
think it's a great order yeah
the knight is defending the pawn but
it's kind of difficult to be both
defending the D pawn and defending the
two points there
can we so there was a move played in the
game Knight to e5 check slowing down any
progress a black can make on the Kings
side but now it seems like black can
very simply play King f4 and perhaps
support the past deep on with a move
like kini 3 and I think that even if the
knight
let's say is sacrificed for both all
three all three pawns there then if the
King captures one b3 the eight point can
be running in any way and again can be
wand that's true there's some may be
long-term possibility is where blacks
king is simply more active than whites
King and could be closer to the this
Queen side pond and b3 probably King III
it's gonna happen so well White has to
choose a square for the knight do you
think maybe Geoffrey would go for a move
like night g6 I think that's what
happened yes 96 and now there's some
debate for black you moved back to g4 or
do you go all out and support your your
D pawn we should analyze this variation
after King III because it looks like
what you were saying just now after
Knight a gauge for d3 Knight f3 black
can very simply play d2 and the
resulting King pawn ending should be
simply winning for black so what if
black doesn't go night if free and try
to check maybe 95 so let's go a little
bit kinky 3 here so Katie 3 9 a cage for
d3 maybe night at 5 I mean I need to try
to get some time maybe if you play king
d2 here then I can recapture on g3 with
a king and I have some extra tempo
that's true and tempo is is incredibly
important in positions like this where
you don't want to waste any time
especially pushing a passed pawn down
the board
I could imagine perhaps a move like King
F for escaping any potential checks
attacking the knight and threatening D -
I don't see immediately how Y it would
deal with this
you know there is a resource for light
to actually take on g3 and after d2 you
can you can get some tempo with check on
e to and then bring the Knight to c3
this might be a saving resource for
white but now if I go to King D screen
King D 3 91
you want to play King C - yes and no
kinks - and even if you go 93 now I
would just first capture the pawn on b3
ok wait you can come back in time King
f2 seems very very complex but what if
you are not in time here let's go to you
with this variation so after King take
me three King f2 I go King B - mmhmm
kingi to King c1 this is looking pretty
Josh I think that the King is uh is
close enough to catch the so I have to
try to promote a pawn before I take upon
on b3 right so a move like 93 could be
met with King c1 as black is is
promoting the pawn but it seems like
White's King could could come back in
time after King f3 we can just play it
out
Queen Mike take d1 King take t1 I think
this is just an easy draw for whites Y
can play just the standard b4 and it's
going to take black a few extra Tempe to
pick up the pawn after a Keeney - King
b3 a king d1 this is just a dead drop
the good part is or for received the
good part is that he still has 33
minutes so he has a lot of time for
calculation to see if some precise lines
may work let's see what are the current
standings now in the group a we have
some results and we see that VAR his
game is still pending he has to point at
some long games today the the games with
vara Cobian and and this game with
receive against Jeffrey are still
pending
if either player if our or of a thief
managed to win their games they'll get
off to a perfect start three out of
three and we also have the games
renacchi mabye of benjamin Boxtel
pending so some long flights today so
let's see what are the pairings for
tomorrow for group a we have benjamin
bach against Verico beyond that it's
gonna be interesting game received our
ballet against Renaud Juma by if Peter
Prohaska against Jeffrey's young yarrow
jariabek against Alexandre Indyk and Sam
Savion against Daniel Friedman certainly
some exciting matchups to look forward
to
let's check out the standings for Group
B given that we just have one game still
pending between Camille dragon and Josh
Goodell the rest of the games have
finished if Camille manages to win his
game he will he will stay perfect three
out of three
so whatever pairings for groupie for
tomorrow we have Daenerys adieu a
cassava playing and race to coffin
Alejandra Ramirez with his student JJ
ally Miranda from the slough University
Sergei Matenga
against Vladimir Bellas Camille dragon
against Robert Alcazar Ian and Tata
abraham ian against her former coach
Joshua Fredo well we saw a lot of lot of
exciting matchups today a lot of still
exciting chess going on if you want to
follow the games you can go to us chess
champs calm and we will be back tomorrow
for Round four starting at 1:00 p.m.
Central Time
the broadcast will start at 3:30 Central
Time see you guys tomorrow see you
tomorrow
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you